did you really drink six martinis before
taping spey wesy dude I was loaded
absolutely loaded I loaded like you
can't imagine and just forgot [__] like
just went out there and I was just like
[__] it I had an attitude at that time
in my life where I was like nobody wants
this so I don't care anyway it's all
over I'm going back to physical therapy
so
[__] it so I just went out there SM I
mean smashed and um but I said [__] it
you know why the hell not that and then
I have the other thing in my career that
people know me from is is my 911 story I
went on if you Google Chris stano 911
story it's like the thing like people
would be like hey you're the 911 guy
which sounds weird I'm like no I wasn't
involved but they but they you know I
did this comedy bit about 911 on 9911 in
New York City at the comedy Celler and
it's another thing I was like nearly
blackout drunk when I did it wow like
almost like I have little fuzzy memories
of it and I it was like the only thing
of my standup that like ever went like
truly viral and I was like holy [__] I
just put out 12 minutes and I and I knew
when I was doing that bit like all the
waiters and waitresses stopped what they
were doing and I saw other Comics coming
into the back of the comedy Celler to
watch and I was like oh [__] what's
happening right now and I just kept
going like telling the story and then I
was like I saw the next day and I was
like dude I don't even remember saying
half of this [__] like I was calling out
like Vinnie guadino from the Jersey
Shore I don't know what I was even
talking about but I showed it to my
friend and he was like you have to put
this out immediately like this is what
you post and I was like nobody's going
to like this he was like just [__]
post what was the gist of it so
basically on 9/11 I told this story
about how my mom worked in downtown
Manhattan in the second uh building that
was hit survived was fine but I didn't
know like where she was like nobody knew
where she was and you know New York City
was like kind of wild on 9/11 and I um I
didn't know where they told us what
happened and then immediately I was like
oh my mom's dead and I started to cry
and this guy Frank this kid Frank
started laughing at me right and it's an
old boy Catholic High School very very
strict High School this kid Frank starts
to laugh at me and I immediately just
broke a chair over his head like we were
sitting in these detached chairs and
desks and I just took the chair and I
swung it over his head [__] like
knocked him out big thing and I got
expelled from the school on 9/11 I get
home my mom is okay you know like I I I
I was like you know she was we didn't
know where she was but I get home and
she's there she's okay and I don't tell
anybody anything and then I go back into
school we were off Wednesday 911
happened on a Tuesday Wednesday school's
closed and then Thursday I walked back
in like I didn't you know almost put
somebody in a coma and then this the
teacher the principal brother Rob was
like Hey Deano what do you think we
forgot you're expelled and I was like oh
sorry you guys remember that and they
were like yeah he Frank's in the
hospital I was like my bad and and and
so I call my father and my father's like
you know kind of like um was in prison
when I was a kid um was like a kind of
in andout you know great guy but like
you know like a a tough old school New
York guy from the Bronx like what you
see in the movies like that's the type
of guy my father was not so much when he
was raised me but he has that in him and
you know it's probably what my mother
was attracted to when they had me and
and all that and so like a kind of tough
guy so I call my dad from pay phone and
I was like Hey Dad I got expelled from
the school and he goes right away he
goes here's the good news no you didn't
and I said no I'm I'm telling you I did
and he goes nope I'm coming down there
I'm going to negotiate with this [__]
you
know so it wasn't like a thing like if I
had told my mother there like I got
expelled or whatever it's what did you
do oh my God my dad cuz he's just been
around criminals and been around stuff
he he just he's calm he was just like
you're not getting don't worry about it
he goes I'm going to be there in 20
minutes I'm going to talk to this guy
now he lived on Staten Island the school
was in Queens this was a Wednesday
morning at 9:30 in the morning it's like
an hour with traffic he got there in
like 15 minutes and I never forget he
showed up he was wearing a New York
Yankees uh batting practice uh a New
York Yankees batting practice jacket and
he had a Dunkin' donut coffee that was
like a tri XL so this guy was like
caffeined up fired up and he walks in
and we walk he's where's the principal's
office so I show them we walk in and
there's uh you know a um secretary there
that you know you need to make
appointments he walks right past her I
never her name was misset misset he
walks right past misset she goes excuse
me uh sir you need have an appointment
he goes I I got don't worry about just
do what you're doing sweetheart I got
one so he walks in and I'm there and
brother Rob is on the phone so my my dad
goes hey can I talk to you and then
brother Rob says do you have an
appointment he goes Noah I don't need
one and he goes no you need one he goes
nah I don't need one he goes can I talk
to you and then brother Rob goes I'm on
the phone and then I'll never forget my
dad you know was like a like a house
phone he clicked the receiver on the
phone and he goes look at that now
you're not on the phone he like hung up
his phone call and then and then he goes
um he goes uh to brother R he's like um
so my son I heard that my son alleged
hit somebody in the head with a chair
and then uh brother Rob goes well it's
not alleged we have he hit somebody in
the head with a chair there's Witnesses
he goes it's all alleged till he's
convicted and he goes brother Rob was
like it's not this is not a court you
know like he's expelled from the school
and then brother Rob was like um listen
he goes uh he's expelled and there's
nothing you can do it my dad's goes
there's got to be another way like he
just one of those doesn't take no for
answer kind of guy so my that goes
there's got to be another way and then
brother Rob goes um there's sir there's
no other way way like he's you know he
he could be arrested for like what he
did there's absolutely no other way and
then my dad takes out a l of cash and he
just put right in front of me just puts
it on the table in front of me goes
there's got to be another way and then
brother Rob says you're going to bribe a
man of God and then on that this is like
it like got etched in my brain he goes I
lost God September 21st 1979 and I'm
like I don't know what that date meant
to him but I know he was in prison and
so I don't even want to know what
happened to him that day but something
definitely crazy happened to him that
day like I I will never ask him but he
was like that September 21st 1979 I was
like oh [__] so then my dad goes let's
figure out another way and then brother
Rob says sir are you stupid there's no
other way and then my dad that's you
don't want to say that to a guy like
that that's like calling Michael J fox
chicken yes exactly and my dad goes um
my dad goes you just call me stupid and
then he looks at me he goes you just
call me stupid and I said yeah you know
yes
um but I don't think he meant it like
that and then my dad goes yeah he goes
Chrissy when he call me like he would
that's what he call me he would go
Chrissy lock the door so I was like what
he goes lock the door so I shut the door
and he goes and he sits down calm my
father he goes um to brother OB he goes
okay listen he goes now you have two
options he goes and he goes the second
option really sucks for you he goes
here's the first option just let my son
back in school
he goes now here's the second option and
again this one's going to suck for you
he goes you're going to think what I'm
about to say is I've heard it in a movie
he's like I'm one of the guys that they
write these movies about he goes I'm
going to come over there and I'm going
to break both of your kneecaps he goes
I've done it before I'll do it again he
goes I will call the police and I will
give them my name my social security
number tell them exactly what I'm doing
and then I'm going to still do it to you
he goes I don't care I'll go he goes I'd
rather this is another exact quote he
goes I'd rather go back to prison for
the rest of my life and be with my
friends then you throw him out and me
have to listen to his mother's [__]
mouth for the rest of my life he goes so
the choice is yours it's up to you and
then brother Rob like why does it go cuz
when you get put in a position like that
and you know like there's this is like a
detached from reality man or at least
he's having temporary insanity type man
you you know like you're like I'm not
like in the movies you might be a tough
guy but in reality you're like I'll do
whatever you want me to do then and then
brother Rob's like okay well then he's
he's back in school he's immediately
he's immediately back in school and then
and then my dad says thank you he goes I
appreciate he goes now we got there
should be a penalty you know he's like
you know detention you know whatever
he's like you know yeah my dad's like
you know you don't get off scott free
with [__] like that but there should be
a penalty he goes how about detention
before and after school and uh we throw
and you know he can't be on the
basketball team or something like that
brother brother Rob goes that's fine
with me and I said Dad break his [__]
legs I'd rather not do you like shopping
on Amazon I do and good news is sto's
butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and sto's butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah d